head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
let's jump to Twitter sure we have this
beautiful tweet from our good friend
Will Chamberlain how's it going well
shout out he says Elon Musk has fired
the curation team the human rights team
the ethics team transparency and
accountability team nothing of value was
lost Bravo so um this individual said
yesterday was my last day at Twitter the
entire human rights team has been cut
from the company why is there a human
rights team at Twitter it is a tech
platform for you to send words to the to
the to people why do they have a human
rights team well according to what I'm
seeing online they were specifically
going after people who were calling for
bodily autonomally calling for medical
freedom and for uh parental rights so
there you go they were going after those
specific individuals
sorry good the curation team uh the
entire curation team was fired
I'm very happy about this because
Twitter once put on their what's Trend
what's happening Trend trending tab for
like two weeks a fake story about me
totally fabricated completely insane and
people were commenting on Twitter being
like why is this really weird fake story
trending when no one's talking about it
it's not relevant it's not political
it's just a hit piece what was the story
um I'm not gonna get into it okay it's
just a fake story fabricated in every
respect okay and Twitter's curation team
decided they should make sure all of
their users see a story that no one
cared about and the response for most
people was like why is this trending
this story is clearly fake
because they're ideological because
these people are are Marxist leftist
cult members and so anything they can do
to attack their ideological enemies they
do so good riddance to them and then we
have Ben Collins he's also one of these
fake news guys he says the entire ethics
transparency and accountability team at
Twitter is gone if you want a sense of
uh where the site is headed where is it
headed where is a tech platform headed
that doesn't have a ethics team you know
look man that's what I call bloat that
guy Ben Collins his uh bio on Twitter is
dystopia beat which is hilarious because
he just runs cover for actual dystopia
yeah he just writes fake stuff right
that's right no I think that um
I I have noticed that I'm being uh
targeted less with like tweets people
and content that I hate whereas like
before I would log in and be bombarded
with like you know Pro Ukrainian War
propaganda people screaming about how
the US needs to get involved and stuff
and I hated it because I don't follow
any of these people like I don't follow
the Kiev post or the key of independent
right but I would I'd open my app and
there would be somebody saying that the
United States has to continue giving
Ukraine Aid like after midterms I mean
why am I seeing this you know God yeah
no it's just I've just noticed that like
in the last few days I don't see that
anymore so Elon musk's Eight dollar plan
is striking at the hearts of U.S cyber
command operations manipulation Etc
so we learned this 10 years ago or so
from this leak that the US government
was producing sock puppet accounts that
private companies would make a series of
fake Bots or Bots and sock puppets a
sock puppet is an account that looks
like a real person that you control so
you know a soccer sock puppet would be
John Doe has 10 accounts one is John Doe
and then he has Jane Doe rickdo Bobby
Smith and he acts like they're different
people then you tweet something like I'm
a big fan of pineapple on pizza and then
all of a sudden you get slammed by just
10 posts all being like you're you're
disgusting that's really awful oh come
on you don't really like that and it
makes you feel like you're being
unpopular all of a sudden people are
attacking you for doing this thing and
so you're like oh you know I was just
kidding I won't but it's one guy with
Elon musking's Eight dollar thing the
ability of the US government and other
intelligence agencies to manipulate
using Bots and sock puppets is gone
because people are going to be like I
don't want to interact with random
Anonymous accounts sorry I'm gonna
ignore ignore don't care yeah I mean
that was something that I commonly heard
was that people who would tweet things
that you know contrary to the consensus
on the war would just be swarmed by by
just a non-tiny and non-counts that were
either just recently created or very few
followers that would all be just be
basically brow like I saw it too like my
I wrote about Ukraine and stuff like I
would get swarmed by these accounts like
these nobodies and a lot of them had
been created in the last year or so I
don't really notice that anymore
I just I tweeted this and a bunch of
people got mad I said something like
stop interacting with Anonymous accounts
on and your experience on Twitter could
become way better and this was maybe
like a year ago and then I had a bunch
of people even like real people be like
you're so you're so wrong Tim opposes
anonymity blah blah and I was like when
did I say you shouldn't be allowed to be
anonymous I said if you don't interact
with them your day is better why look
you're allowed to be anonymous I don't
care I think it's good in a lot of ways
but don't expect me to waste time with
1. 1.3 million people you know if if
they're all using cartoon communist
squirrels like dude I am not going to
argue with someone I can't see I'm not
going I hear I hear muttering through
the wall I'm not gonna start screaming
at the wall I'm gonna ignore it someone
gets on Twitter they don't want to show
their face they don't want to use their
real name you can't expect me to engage
with a million plus people doing that
sorry I see somebody who uses their name
Will Chamberlain right we we brought him
up it's a picture of him and his family
and it's his real name so there's a
strong likelihood I'm actually talking
to someone and that could that could be
fruitful for me I won't be wasting my
time I don't know man you could you
could have a cartoon a communist
squirrel account and it's probably the
same guy arguing with me from 10
different accounts I'm not going to
waste my time with that you're allowed
to be anonymous I got no beef with that
I'm just saying don't expect me to give
you my time if you don't show me your
face I originally taken it to the
extreme and said if you don't make a
video and speak so I can hear your voice
and look in your eyes I'm not going to
respond to you because I don't believe
who that you're who you say you are it's
a little extreme because like I know
Will Chamberlain personally and I know
that's his Twitter account so there are
cases where I'll respond to some texts
and every now I'm a little more relaxed
on it now I want to kind of involve
people but I'm not going to get stressed
out by text go ahead I just want to
point out real quick with the
termination of all of these uh uh teams
this means that right before the
midterms if a hunter Biden laptop story
came out there's no weirdo to censor it
yeah so like the Paul Pelosi thing yeah
it's it's that's it free speech no I
think you're already kind of seeing this
again it might be just be perception
because you know we're excited about the
possibilities of musk making uh
twitterless cancerous but it I mean it
does seem like uh things are getting
through uh but on the point of announce
like I I follow a few anons but the ones
that I follow are like they're high
follower counts typically uh right that
I've shown that like they're either like
historians or you know like independent
Scholars uh I think I think good anons
can be really constructive and you can
learn a lot from them but yeah I think
there's
a a problem with these these sock
accounts basically right just I follow
swarming well it's not just suck
accounts it's psychological operations
Israel first started to talk about how
they were hiring tens of thousands of
individuals that would just go online
and of course actively work on setting
the perception online as Israel being
more favorable than anyone else the
United States the Pentagon of course
have a similar program but I agree with
you there's a fine balance because we
still should have privacy but at the
same time we've got to be careful when
it comes to the psychological operations
which seems like Elon Musk is disrupting
what will be the price for that
disruption how will the the Deep state
to the the Pentagon and all these other
large government institutions that
depend on this for their larger
psychological operations response to
this that's another question that I
think we should worry about oh man I
want you to imagine
what a feature is going to look like
if if Elon Musk has his way if the
Republicans win on Tuesday I'm imagining
mixed race families hanging out in their
front porch the dad's playing catch with
his son he smiles
then the pizza man delivers it off
there's a there's a milk crate from the
Milkman there's two more push-ups it's
going to be nuts kids healthy everyone's
fit no fat people anywhere oh I'm so
terrified yeah a lot of this now here's
the scariest part
they go to church on Sundays
the bad that my fantasy is is much more
like vengeful
yeah I want to hurt these people because
they've been trying to hurt me and like
not decent Americans that's a bad way to
put it we want to fix the problems you
don't want to become what you're
fighting no I don't mean I mean I think
well do you want to be what they are I
want to I will leave that one go but no
I think I I think the reality is in
order to fix this country like you're
going to do things that are going to
like like the transgenderism right
taking on transgenderism is going to
make heads explode uh and you would have
to necessarily shut down institutions
like you would have to attack uh the
accreditation of Clinics of hospitals
now you're helping people right it is
look yes yes that's right I know what
you mean I don't want to hurt yeah we
don't but I'm willing to change the
banking system and people will lose
their job so you could argue well then
they were hurt but that's exactly that's
what I mean yes you have so many stories
of D transitioners who wish they never
went through with it and their lives are
uh you know irreparably harmed so when
you start coming in and following the
science yeah and actually stopping uh
you know the bad stuff you're actually
helping yes a lot of these people that's
right so you take a look at what's going
on in in Europe and they've already
started doing away with a lot of that
stuff in the U.S they're just the left
is a cult they're they're obstinate
unwilling to look at the data they
believe what the media tells them they
believe with what the government tells
them and that leads people to dangerous
dangerous places we need we need to stop
all that and actually just try and be
you know calm about things
and genuinely help everyone so the end
result is I I don't I don't know the
Republicans are going to solve all the
problems I I honestly think they won't I
think there's a handful of good ones
that will will do some good things
they're saying that uh uh Rand Paul will
be the head of like the health committee
or something like that awesome yeah I
don't know I saw that on Twitter and I'm
like oh fauci must be sweating bullets
hey that sounds really good if they win
so let's let's get that to happen at the
very least but the end result of this is
we're not seeking to hurt anybody
nobody's getting hurt we're getting
Justice and accountability when you
arrest a guy who robbed a liquor store
you're not hurting him he may be hurt in
the arrest I get that but we're
ultimately doing it because we want to
help everyone and stop this guy from
from doing wrong ideally in my in my
view we would arrest someone because we
are trying to help them we're trying to
rehabilitate unfortunately I think we
need prison reform and Criminal Justice
Reform because too often we don't do
that but the end result should be we are
we we are better than they are we don't
we don't go out and burn down buildings
in Riot like antifa does we don't
justify the violence and then lie about
it everything that's happened from this
eclectic bunch of people from
libertarian post-liberal and
conservative has been to make everyone's
life better
and the problem is the left exploits The
Good Will and good faith of those trying
to actually help people
yeah I just think that in order to
really like I said do the things that
need to be done like we have to be
willing to to become a little bit more
ruthless with power I mean by holding
people accountable for things like
transgenerism for covid I mean like
you're talking about like I I don't I'm
not just kidding when I say we we should
have military tribunals for the people
that thought it would be a good idea to
lock people in their homes and force
yeah you don't do a Military Tribunal
for Citizens you do a normal prosecution
like you you don't bring in the Army to
arrest people for a civil right well you
you understand what I'm saying like I
think the the yeah you just arrest them
you arrest them we charge them and we we
first we we get Rand Paul on the health
committee however it's called then he
launches investigations file subpoenas
then Congress can you know start making
criminal referrals then uh after the
Republicans get in in 2024 we can weed
out the corruption in the doj it's gonna
take a long time but the solution is
a fairly more normal
Congressional inquiries Federal
investigations special counsels arrests
and I I think that's the path to go for
uh go for thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time